Film Courage: How did you get your first Hollywood
writing job? Glenn Gers, Screenwriter: It
was a fluke, a freak occurrence. It was actually
a script that I had written 10 years before.
It was my first script and I had gotten an
agent with my first script. I'd gotten very
lucky. I knew someone who knew someone who
showed it to an agent who picked me up as
their client but they could not get me. There
had been a very small option during the 10
years other than that I was office temping
and administrative assistanting and doing
some development work for indie companies
and I was beginning to think I should stop
because I was actually planning to become
a teacher, like maybe a high school teacher
or college teacher if I could because at least
I would have summer vacations to write. It
was always what can I do to support my writing
that never stopped but the idea of becoming
a screenwriter stopped because I was like
why keep beating my head against the wall?
I had written a bunch of scripts, I had an
agent. If I wasn't making it maybe I should
quit um but the the first script i had written
all of my scripts were well liked by the people
who read them they just were like this is
really good we just can't make it for a billion
reasons there's always a billion reasons why
people can't do things um but a an independent
producer who really loved one of my scripts
and i had done some rewrites with her um her
name was mae wathridge and she um took a job
at tribeca films when it was just starting
and um she had to say that she was stopping
her independent career and going to work for
tribeca but she had the opportunity uh she
met with someone who works with billy crystal
who was looking to work with de niro on uh
what turned out to be analyzed this eventually
after i failed them um but they they were
looking to work together and may slipped them
my script and they loved it and they said
this this would work very well and so all
of a sudden tribeca had to pick me up as like
oh i guess we'll pick up his script to take
so all of a sudden from being about to quit
i was working with big hollywood stars and
my agent lisa calamaro arranged a fabulous
option and first step deal and all of a sudden
i didn't have to work temp for a year while
i did rewrites on that project which went
so fast downhill and died completely and the
um they wanted changes that i didn't know
how to make and i had worked for 10 years
learning how to write what was in my head
and i had never learned about the part of
hollywood writing where somebody says change
that that wasn't even on my radar and this
was a long time ago this was in the late 1980s
it just never occurred to me that like someone
would say as they did it was the story was
about a divorcing couple a couple who had
gotten divorced and remarried and um divorced
again and over political differences and then
the guy gets involved in espionage and politics
and things and so their divorce the topic
of their divorce becomes the subject of the
thriller and so it was sort of a thriller
romantic comedy and the note was can you take
out the divorce and and it was a completely
legitimate note in one way if you were a flexible
hollywood writer who understood how to rethink
things there are ways to do that and i actually
did that later on another script where i took
out what i considered the center of the story
at the time i had never had that question
raised and i tried so hard i i was just like
i got to do this this is my big break and
i'm blowing it um but i couldn't i wrote an
entire script i've actually it's the only
thing i've ever written that i have never
looked at since it's 30 years now i wrote
it i literally cried through much of the writing
like i was a basket case because i was writing
something that i didn't know what the center
was because for me the center of this story
the reason that everyone was doing something
was because of this couple trying to get back
together when you take that out all you've
got is a bunch of people chasing each other
in funny ways but still wasn't enough to make
a scene i wrote a script i have no idea if
it's readable but i got immediately fired
uh the script went on on the shelf and they
hired new writers and for three years they
held on to it and niro and crystal wisely
moved on did analyze this it was a good choice
on their part um and at the end of that three
years i got my script back which was cool
because i had been well paid to let them have
it for three years i had never seen any of
the rewrites that were done after i did it
so therefore i was i was allowed to take everything
i had done that was my property the script
i the draft i done for them was their property
because they paid me for it but the option
was over and i just started sending it out
again and i so many people loved it and got
so close to production so many times but what
it taught me was the thing that i thought
writing was about which is you imagine stuff
and you get it down as good as you can and
then they pay you and they make it that's
not how the industry works the industry works
that you do all that stuff and then you start
to collaborate with other people and if you
can't do that part if you can't learn how
to use those same creative skills on demand
for things you may not think are great then
they'll find someone who can does that sound
depressing it's not meant to it's meant to
it's meant to say learn the mechanics of the
business so that you can do the job that's
that's the message i hope is being sent there
is that there is the magic of creativity and
then there's the magic of being skilled and
knowing how to do the job no matter what gets
thrown at you well i think it's very important
that you bring up that story because so many
ideas of something sound great and then when
you learn what they actually are it's much
much different so that's just fascinating
so it was a year that you had to rewrite that
or that was a year process it was a year of
actually this is it's a funny story so i'll
tell it uh it's embarrassing um i got once
i took out the center of the story i didn't
know what the story would be and i what i
do is that when i don't know what i'm going
to write i just riff i think of everything
i can i brainstorm it could be this it could
be that you know we're on a submarine it could
be the submarine's at the bottom of the sea
it could be at the submarine got moved to
dry land where you know everything i can possibly
think i try and get it down on paper there's
no such thing as a bad idea until you've figured
out what you're trying to accomplish with
it anything's possible so i had this huge
list of possibilities of this story and i
didn't know which one they wanted and i was
writing for them so um i made it into a board
game i actually i was working as an office
temp still so i had access to like a laminating
machine everything and i made a board and
it was like it was like the game of life where
you go along a path but this had like multiple
branching paths for each story and and i tried
to lay out all the different story outlines
as a board game with like cards like if you
pick this you go in this tray it was the most
elaborate creative stupid thing i've ever
done and i brought it to billy crystal i got
an appointment i flew to los angeles i gave
it to him and i said this is your story outline
i don't know which one you want and he was
really gracious about it and he was he was
great he was like you know well now i have
something to put on the wall of my office
but now we actually have to write the script
after work and he gave me advice and i worked
on it and i did a draft and it was all fine
but that was how little i understood the job
the job by the way is making choices the point
is when i when you lay out the 15 000 possible
stories you have to make a choice everything
is a choice every choice has a price you have
to learn to get comfortable with making choices
over and over and over again everything in
creative work is i'm going to choose this
and not that if i choose this that means that
i can't have a happy ending if i choose this
it means i can't talk about communism versus
capitalism you know whatever it is that you
want to do it's a choice and when you make
that choice certain things fall away but other
things become stronger that's the creative
process and everyone gets very afraid of that
what if i make the wrong choice the coolest
thing is whatever a writer is to get comfortable
with you know what it's a choice i'm gonna
make it i make it judging i know that the
producers want this well no more choice that's
what i'm doing if you don't know for sure
you change you take the choice and you follow
that path you're gambling maybe it'll work
maybe it won't but it's better to make the
choice and be creative and try and find your
solutions than to try and do both that's the
one thing you can't do got to make a choice
and you have to live with the price when they
asked you to take out which what was the center
of the story which is the couple getting divorced
and getting back together did they didn't
tell you what to replace it with they didn't
know when people give you notes they don't
know how to fix it they they just like you
know that seems seems a little wrong or sometimes
they'll know how to fix it but it's not what
you thought would be like you might have a
better one it doesn't matter what matters
is that everyone is going to see things differently
and most notes are this isn't working not
do this if they would do this then it's like
i'll do that most notes are that's not making
sense or that's too slow or that's too fast
but how you actually solve it that's your
task and so for you that was so new it never
occurred to me it was you know people didn't
know that much about screenwriting in the
late 80s early 90s like it wasn't as much
of a thing people didn't do it as much as
they do now now everybody writes scripts um
and frankly everyone should because now everyone
can make them um but at the time the experience
of being a professional writer was not very
well known um there were only a handful of
books and in fact the first time i came to
la um i was my agent had come out and she
had set me up with meetings and everyone said
to me your work is good you could work here
if you moved here um but you would be have
to get used to writing things that didn't
get made because at the time that was how
development worked they would develop 50 scripts
and make one which meant 49 writers were writing
a script that was going to be put on a drawer
never seen again and they would be highly
paid and they would be well respected and
maybe one of them would get lucky at one of
your scripts would would hit but you never
knew some people had a full career never getting
anything made and that blew my mind i was
like i'm not going to work a whole year on
a script and not have anyone see it which
of course that's the business that's the job
but at the time i didn't know i had no clue
and it took me a while to process that and
to recognize that as a day job goes pretty
cool you learn a lot on it and you get paid
to do the thing you love but it may get put
on the shelf you may never see it again when
you came back to them with other ideas which
could be the center of the story did they
not like it or that was the board game all
right this is the the process by which this
happens is that the people who are in charge
like if you're a star or a director and you're
supervising writers you know that you're not
a writer and so you just try to guide them
as some are better than others and it's it's
the writer's job to translate the notes that's
part of being a professional screenwriter
is recognizing that people are going to tell
you stuff and you have to figure out what
i believe is you have to figure out how to
turn it into scenes everything about screenwriting
is how to think in scenes if you can figure
out how to make a scene out of an idea or
a desire or whatever it is that somebody says
then you can be a professional writer and
um so very often the people in charge will
say like honestly you know i know what end
result i want but i don't know how to get
there that's your job um so that was a lot
of the notes were like that and in fact i
said i said here's the thing when it really
comes down to it there's a big there's a binary
choice there's a this or that you know is
it this ending or that ending and the note
was well could it be both
what are you going to do so eventually i just
chose i actually think this board game is
kind of cool but it was great i wish i don't
know if i have a copy of it i think i gave
him the only copy that's kind of a neat idea
i mean if someone had the time to make the
board game that that would be yeah absolutely
no i mean essentially it's create your own
story which is now a completely legitimate
creative project you know you could you can
you know digitally you can make a story that
you could do that with i think it's called
a video game you know and um so i just was
decades ahead of my there you go i should
have been designing games.
Question For The Viewers: What did you like
about this video?